most people starting recruitment with a
team of people around them however big
or small that team might be and you are
taking guidance from the people around
you and something I'm really big on is
just surrounding yourself with good
human beings like genuine human beings
who are authentic hard-working doesn't
mean that you share all the same beliefs
doesn't mean that you even come from the
same background for me just means that
you see something in them where you're
like I can absolutely see myself working
with this person learning from this
person being inspired by this person or
maybe inspiring them it needs to be like
a mutual I think transaction where all
of you are going to benefit from being
around each other and being in each
other's company welcome back to another
episode of the recruitment mentors
podcast I'm your host heisha mizzouz and
on this week's episode I was joined by
Daniel Lawson who for the last 16 years
has been building a career in
recruitment for the last seven he's been
building and climbing the ranks at
signify he was their very first employee
in 2016. where he joined Ryan Adams with
a big Vision to disrupt the tech
industry for those of you that have
listened to the podcast for a while you
would have heard and listened to the
inspiring story of Ryan who started
signify and if you haven't I'd highly
recommend checking that out in this
episode we spoke about Dan's approach to
leadership it doesn't need to be
Cutthroat and Dan's really lent into
being authentic and remaining himself
whilst building a successful Korean
recruitment as well as this we talk
about principles to landing and
expanding winning business building High
performing teams and so much more enjoy
the episode and welcome to the podcast
thanks for having me appreciate you uh
making the trip obviously uh you grew up
in London right yeah South London uh
Clapham and I only moved to Manchester
in October 2020. it's always saying we
uh prefer the North
lock it down south how do you feel when
you come back I mean London's got my
heart always but yeah I'm loving being
in north right now
um Manchester is a really cool and
special City so I'm enjoying my time
there yeah I love that
um so look obviously we've sort of got
to know each other just in different
ways really spoken about the podcast you
came to one on the live podcast events
which I saw you at last time
so yeah really looking forward to
dissecting and uncovering this journey
that uh you've been on uh so like you
were just saying uh coming up to 16
years in recruitment that's nearly two
decades my friend that is a long time
yeah it's crazy that is a commitment to
the craft yeah
um but obviously over the last seven
years uh you've been on this amazing
journey with signify so I think what
we're gonna focus on today is really go
into that journey of what you've learned
um and everything else but just to give
people listening just a couple of
highlights
um obviously we've had Ryan on the
podcast that we've also had uh Susan on
the podcast as well a while ago but you
as one of the the first employees in
2016 to join uh Ryan right at the
beginning
um but then in 2020 you moved to
Manchester as you just said and you've
been involved in and building that team
um for the business over the last couple
of years and now you're are you
associate director yeah now and
obviously you've you've grown into that
role over the the last uh seven years so
I think today we're going to talk about
leadership talking about culture
building High performing teams I know
something you're known for is landing
and expanding sound good to you yeah all
good let's get stuck in so let's start
with the the million pound question like
from your perspective I'd love to sort
of hear how you think about this but
what what do you believe are the sort of
common characteristics and traits of a
successful recruiting in today's market
yeah so um I've listened to a lot of
your podcasts and I think all the
answers that people give are absolutely
spot on so being resilient being
motivated being coachable uh being
driven they're all absolutely correct
but for me all those things link back to
personal accountability and for me I
think that's what I would say is the
real sort of thing that underpins like
what makes a recruiter successful
because you know if you haven't got that
within you to you know be driven and be
motivated and to find solutions to
problems then you know if you're
constantly blaming everything can
everyone else and it's the Market's
fault or you know my managers this or
you know you guys haven't done that but
if you're not constantly looking at
yourself and being like regardless of
all that stuff that's going on I need to
focus on what's in my control and it
might not be my fault that that's
happened or that's the situation but
it's abs absolutely my responsibility to
still find the way to you know control
what's in my what control the
controllables and you know find a way to
to get the solution that I need
I really like that I'm I'm big on that
as well like that's
I'm really curious here then like
because if that's really important to
you that's clearly something that you
surely like that's something that you
have top of mind when you're looking for
people in your team or that's definitely
gonna be I'm assuming something that
you're looking for people to have within
your team
how how have you found that because I
don't think everyone has that do you
think like do you know what I mean so
like do you feel like can if someone
doesn't have it can they sort of learn
to be more personally responsible
because I think particularly in in
recruitment it is very easy to point the
finger but then I think in in today's
world it's also really easy to point the
finger and be like well I should be here
or is that person's fault or you know
like there's so many things that we can
blame uh things on so have you oh yeah
have you found that you've been able to
cultivate that in people is it something
you think there's people having lately
or they don't
yeah that's a good question I think the
way that I view that is I think you
definitely can become more personally
accountable
um you can definitely see people who
have those traits within them already
and I think you know by and large it is
I think quite innate within people but
I'm a big believer in people can grow
develop adapt as well so I think if it's
not something that comes naturally to
you you absolutely can learn to be more
personally accountable and I think my
role as a leader I've always tried to
you know without being uh you know
preachy and you know I'm always
conscious of not coming across as like
preaching to people but just painting
the picture for people as to you know
this is the world that we live in you
know
um you know absolutely all this stuff
goes on it's you know a tough Market
there's things that might have been
um done to you that aren't your fault
but it's still your responsibility to
you know find the way through that you
know it's no one else's responsibility
no one owes you anything so
um I think yeah that's something I
definitely look for when I'm
interviewing people for my team and for
the business
um and if it's not something that comes
naturally to them then I absolutely try
and you know give them that guidance and
you know show them the reasons why it's
better to have that mindset and you know
what's the benefit going to be to them
of having that mindset or cultivating
that mindset and I think that's benefit
in work and outside of work as well
absolutely that's the thing so just
quickly on that then because I think
it'll be useful for people
how how do you try and uncover that in
an interview you know are you going for
like I don't know you get them to sort
of think about a scenario and you try
and look out for if they go yeah I
didn't do this because of my manager or
how do you try and sort of you know
find that in people yeah I think some of
the questions that I asked in my
interviews is you know I asked people to
tell me you know what some of the
toughest or hardest situations that
you've been through you know whether
that's in work or outside of work and
what I'm looking to see there is you
know how they describe that situation
what was the you know how did it make
them feel what was their solution to it
did they just accept it you know did
they think no you know [__] this I'm
going to find a solution to this I'm
gonna you know this has happened it's
really [__] but I'm gonna find a way
through this that's the sort of things
that I I look for but that's the
question I really like asking people and
it is quite deep you know I don't think
um a lot of people in recruitment or any
interview for a career or work job might
ask that but that's something that's
definitely important to me and I I
really like to uncover that in people
so I just wanted to to start before we
go into leadership principles Business
Development this journey that you've
been on but some something that sort of
stuck out to me when we were sort of
preparing for this
um was obviously you've worked for
um a few different
um companies in the 16 years right but
obviously with the for the last seven
it's been signify and obviously you and
Ryan are good threatens yeah but sort of
what we what you were sharing with me
was like how you believe it's really
important that you try and do everything
that you can to find yourself in an
organization where you really align with
the leader that is leading that business
yeah so why don't you just talk to us a
bit about why why you think that's
important and then also
um how how uh Ryan has enabled you to
feel like you know what this is someone
that I can really get behind is someone
that I really um buy into and that's
obviously clearly been a big reason as
to why we've been continued to grow your
career there yeah I think it's really
important because at any stage in your
career unless you are you know working
for yourself you know in your own
company most people starting recruitment
with you know a team of people around
them
um however big or small that team might
be and you are taking guidance from the
people around you and something I'm
really big on is just surrounding
yourself with good human beings like
genuine human beings who are authentic
hard-working actually just [__] nice
people as well like it's um it's such a
bit of a cliche but for me personally
those are all characteristics that I I
resonate with um so for me any business
that I have always been a part of has
been down to the people that I've met
and interviewed with and I thought
actually I I can align with this person
it doesn't mean that you share all the
same beliefs doesn't mean that you even
come from the same background for me
just means that you see something in
them where you're like I can absolutely
see myself working with this person
learning from this person being inspired
by this person or maybe inspiring them
it needs to be like a mutual I think
transaction where you're both or all of
you are going to benefit from from being
around each other and you know being in
each other's company and do we think
that just makes
work more fun more enjoyable the journey
more enjoyable 100 yeah I mean
especially in recruitment you are
working long hours a lot of the time you
know you're with these people for more
than you might be with your you know
family in a lot of cases so
um that's something that I've always
tried to you know
um
keep in mind when I'm choosing any
organization or team to to work with you
know who are the people that I'm going
to be surrounding myself with
um and I think you know whenever I think
about my time at signify as well and
yeah me and Ryan have got the
long-standing relationship you know
we've been friends for over 20 years now
um best friends and I always think you
know would I be as passionate about
signify would I be as proud to work
there if we didn't have that
relationship and I actually really would
because I absolutely believe in Ryan as
a leader as a person as someone who
um I've learned from you know I'm a
better recruiter and person because Ryan
is someone that I've you know aligned
myself with from a friendship point of
view but also from a business point of
view that's amazing
so what I wanted to just start with
because this this seemed when we're
talking about preparing for this this is
something that I think felt quite
important uh to you so so the question
that I have was like how how do you uh
think aspiring recruitment professionals
can stay true to themselves throughout
their careers
like why don't we just start by just
talking about why why that's been
important in in your journey like just
yeah being true to yourself yeah I
I mean this is you know quite a deep
topic to be honest but
I think ultimately in you know
recruitment your career uh the world
there are so many outside influences you
know telling you you need to be this you
need to do that you know and almost
telling you what the world or society's
definition of success should be um and I
think you know as I've gotten older I've
certainly become more independent in my
thinking in the way that I
um view situations in the world
but something that I was told really
early in my recruitment career was you
know you need to be more of a [__] sorry
that's the reality of it yeah um you
need to be you know you need to be
nastier
um whereas you know innately I'm not
that this needs to be a cop throat but
it needs to be cut through you need to
be ruthless and I think there's
absolutely some truth in that you know I
think you can always take aspects and
characteristics from other people that
you know have been successful and that
you admire their traits but you still
ultimately need to be who you are and be
true to yourself and I think as I've
gone through my career and I've you know
achieved you know a relative level of um
success you know I've had promotions
I've managed teams I've helped other
recruiters you know from day one become
really successful recruiters you know
I've learned from myself and my own
experience is that you can absolutely be
yourself while still striving to be a
better version of yourself but not
compromising what is true to you and
what your values are as a human being I
think there is a time to be direct and
you know straight to the point and you
know maybe a little bit blunt at times
just say how it is I think all those
things are really important but
for me I I try to lead and engage with
people from an empathetic point of view
um and that's something which has always
worked really well for me
um there have been times where maybe
people have taken advantage of it to be
honest
um but for me I just take those
experiences as learning situations where
right maybe next time I won't do it that
way but I'm still going to be true to
myself and what I think is important to
me I think that's amazing that
you yeah I think that's such a great way
to approach your career life because
yeah being able to look yourself in the
mirror and go you know what I knew I did
everything I could I knew that I sort of
yeah like you said was true to yourself
yeah you're gonna be able to sleep way
better at night compared to the other
people that do things just to because
they think they need to be something
else or
those things I guess just curious then
like I'm assuming it was a journey to
get to that point
because that takes a lot of Courage I
feel like just to sort of own what you
are what you stand for
um despite maybe external factors going
down you need to be something else how
did it how did it sort of affect you or
how did you feel being in environments
then where you probably felt like you
know what actually this actually doesn't
really line with me that I am actually
really trying to I'm probably being
quite out of character here or I'm doing
things that I probably don't do but I
don't overly believe in but I have to do
them because it's my like how did that
yeah how did how did that affect you
one thing that I always try to do is not
to take any situation that's like the
Buell and end all and what I mean by
that is you know you can be in certain
rooms or situations or you know with
certain people and I think nowadays it's
very much you know you're either all of
this or all of that there's no Nuance or
there's no you know space to be well
actually maybe I don't agree with
everything that that person does or what
this company does but I'm still learning
a lot from this company as well whereas
I think these days it's very easy to be
like well no I don't like that one thing
about the company so I'm just gonna
switch off disengage completely and
almost self-sabotage so I've always been
like very I guess analytical of whatever
situation or organization or even people
that I engage with and think well yeah
maybe there's some of their traits that
don't align with me and who I am but
there's absolutely sore stuff that I can
learn from this person and add to my
game to make me a better person make me
a better recruiter make me a better
leader so I think it's that analytical
um mindset and not just taking things as
right as all of this or all of that I
can take some of this and some of that
and use that to better myself yeah it's
not black or white yeah I absolutely
love that I I couldn't agree with like a
whole different conversation but I think
that is also probably a good description
of like just
just Society right now as well in terms
of you're either like in this Camp
you're either in that camp or if you
were in that camp down then I don't like
you because you have those beliefs you
know what I mean so just on this end and
then we'll move on because you've you've
clearly showcased this already in this
conversation which I love but where how
have you gone about cultivating this
mindset then because what I hear there
is perspective uh personal
responsibility you're willing to go okay
like what can I learn from even though
it's a challenging uh situation not
everyone not everyone has that ability
to have that perspective to have the
responsibility so just talk to us a bit
about how you've sort of how in your
life you've got to that point of having
those types of approaches uh to things
in your mindset because I think again
like if more people can have more of
those
um approaches and perspectives to things
that it can help them in their life
inside work and outside of work but
where have you gone about cultivating
this mindset yeah so I'm I'm really big
on like personal development as well
setting goals and it's probably not
something I really did with any real
conviction or belief when I first
started in recruitment as most people
did you know I fell into recruitment you
know wanted to earn a good wage gone a
few holidays and you know things like
that but
I think it was really coinciding with my
time joining signify speaking with Ryan
about the goals that he had of wanting
to start his own company and thinking
actually this is this is pretty sick
what he's talking about this could
literally change our lives
um and something that Ryan's always been
big on is setting personal goals and you
know um personal development so that
could be listen to podcasts reading
books
um even like working out
um so I think probably starting around
the time when we first launched the
business back in 2016 that's when I
really I guess started taking
I guess um your own development services
yeah taking my own development really
seriously
um and that's not to say that it's been
perfect you know all human beings I'm a
human being there are definitely times
when I fall off of that and you know you
get into the routine of just you know
going through the motions so to speak
but what I try to do is not stay there
too long so I am I definitely believe in
like reading books uh listening to
podcasts and for me it's all about
positive like reinforcements and
positive
consuming positive information because
there's a lot of you know negative stuff
out there so
um I just try and make sure that I'm
constantly
um feeding my brain with like positive
information positive affirmations and I
think that the time where I know it's
the biggest I guess shift in my career
um you know my earnings was when I
really started taking that stuff
seriously um
so yeah I think that's something that I
I would say helps you to have that
mindset
I love that I think it's amazing isn't
it that just what you're talking about
there is just you're really just trying
to commit to be better than you was
yesterday yeah and like yeah what a
great way to approach life I mean that's
such a great thing and something that I
spend a lot of time thinking about and
just yeah just really trying to describe
to be better you know yeah um and it's
hard right because we are human beings
and you know I definitely don't want to
sit here and sound like I'm perfect at
it and I do this all the time and you
know 24 7 this is who I am because I
definitely don't I still make a lot of
mistakes
um but I think innately I'm I'm someone
who doesn't sit in a negative place for
too long I won't beat myself up too long
I'll definitely have myself accountable
but it's more from a right you know I
haven't been gym for a week I haven't
done the run for a while though I
haven't listened to any positive
podcasts for a while or listen to any
like positive videos for a while make
sure I do it now even if it's like 10
minutes just like don't stay in that
negative place for too long
um
get back to that positive place as
quickly as you can
so let's let's move this on a bit let's
I guess why don't we like a big part of
your journey has been leadership right
so why don't we just focus on that for a
second because I'd love to sort of
um hear about how you've um approached
this on on your journey so far obviously
so many people in the the recruitment
industry end up in leadership positions
because of their performance
so for me my perspective is there's so
many people in the industry that are in
those leadership seats that have never
um been uh taught or helped how to coach
uh how to uncover drivers how to get the
best out of their team it's very much
just the like yeah though it may be the
top performer or they perform really
well so it's like okay downright you're
you've got plenty of jobs in get two
three more people underneath you get
them doing what you're doing and Happy
Days
so why don't we just sort of talk
firstly about like when you were um
early on with your leadership Journey
and you were managing um more people I
think you said to me that when you moved
to Manchester the peak there was like 10
people what's been like the most amount
of people that you've been responsible
for yeah so
in London uh we got our London perm team
up to 13 people which are all
responsible I was all I was responsible
for all of them
um and then in obviously that was a team
within an office already whereas uh
Manchester has been my own okay slightly
different
um each has their own challenges
um and you know
um things that you enjoy about them but
so why don't we so let's just talk about
early on then what what did you struggle
most with like when you're really trying
to get to grips with okay I'm now not
just sort of contributing myself I'm not
just thinking about how many fillable
jobs can I put this month what are my
billing targets you're now thinking
about
13 other humans
um how can I help them achieve their
goals how can I make sure they're
hitting their targets I'm wanting to
make sure Ryan's happy because I've got
a net fee income goal that I need to hit
like what what did you initially really
struggle with yeah so I think the first
thing was going from being seen as I
guess one of the team you know your
senior or principal consultant in that
team and to a lot of people you're their
friend you know that's something which
is pretty natural right spend a lot of
time with these people for the most part
you get on with them so they see you as
their friend
um although you might have helped them
or mentored them but not in an official
capacity I think when it becomes
official you're actually their leader in
their boss I think sometimes that
transition period of going from being
seen as the same level as them to now
I'm your you know I'm your leader
that can be quite hard to to manage
um from both parts you know from my
perspective I certainly found that hard
um and I think maybe some people in the
business found that hard as well I think
the thing that I did have on my side was
that because I was there from the very
beginning people have naturally maybe
Associated me with being someone who was
quite senior quite responsible and then
I I found a way to
I guess you have to separate yourself a
little bit um and show them that you can
add value to them as their leader as
well so that people do see you as
credible and someone who can help them
get to whatever their goals might be
what are some of the ways that you can
add value
so I I'm a big believer in just showing
people The Good The Bad and everything
in between as well so if I'm doing a
basic candidate qualification call I'll
be like oh guys jump on this call like
listen to how I qualify this person
um and then afterwards we'll debrief on
that and they'll be like asking
questions I and I might explain to them
why I asked a certain question at a
certain time
um if I'm picking up a new client role
you know I might get them to jump on
that as well
um or if I'm about to jump on the call
which I know is going to be really
difficult it might be we've had a drop
out you know from one of our clients and
the client will have a chat about it
I'll be like guys this call is probably
going to be a bit sticky
um come and listen to how I handle it
um and all you're trying to do there is
show them that you know any situation in
recruitment you can get through it um
and it's not always going to be pretty
it's not always going to be what the
textbooks answers are but here's how I
would approach that situation and
hopefully give them the confidence that
there isn't any situation that they
should be fearful of or you know it
should should not feel that they have
the skill set or within our team we have
the skill set to to I guess get over
that situation so what I take from that
then is by you doing that you're also
helping them to become better because
yeah so yeah one yeah that's it is it is
interesting right because it's like that
may sound really obvious but actually if
you're a recruiter that has a team of
six seven people you still got a number
that you have to hit
uh looking at I don't know the last
month or even the last week how many
opportunities did you give your team
yourself as a manager
um that enabled your team to potentially
improve don't know it might just be in
the one-on-ones where you give direct
feedback or like just those examples
there that's a great way to one you're
leading by the front you're doing the
doing so you're not above them in that
sense right you're doing the things that
they're having to do and you're showing
look I'm I'm willing to do these things
yeah that should mean that you should
definitely be willing to do them right
that's exactly it and then also the way
that you spoke about that was then like
you're also giving them a a learning
opportunity and oftentimes when I speak
to people most of the time they're just
learning on the job yeah so by you
adding value you're actually helping
them become better recruiters so it's
like if you're listening to this you
know manager it's like okay well how can
I create those intentional moments to
help my team get better rather than just
be like do this do that yeah absolutely
so how did you you said separation there
I've got a few friends
um in recruitment sort of yeah bit
similar to you climb the ranks
and they're now sort of seeing that
you're almost end up putting in this
category like Associated like
particularly for people that may be join
like uh they're early on in their
careers you know and
then I'm assuming you mentioned a
separation piece there because then when
you do have fun yourself having to give
direct feedback this isn't good enough
this is why this is where it needs to be
that's probably a bit easier rather than
oh maybe we're just down we was in the
pub last night having a good chat
talking about footy or that how did you
separate yourself did you start not
going to the many socials like I don't
know how did you approach separating you
know the manager friend line yeah I
think with that you have to be authentic
again coming out to who you are as a
person so
um the team my team definitely know who
I am as a person and they know that I
can absolutely be you know friendly with
them and you know I care about them as
human beings and individuals you know
even put the work stuff aside from them
I genuinely care about them as people so
I can still know that they might have
stuff going on outside of work and you
know they're maybe struggling with that
at the moment but you know when we're in
work that's our time to be focused on
the work
um and I think it comes from having that
really clear communication with them
from day one one about you know these
are my expectations this is who I am as
a person I absolutely back you support
you
you know be there for you but we've got
a job to do you know we've got targets
to hit and that makes it easier to frame
any conversation that you might need to
have with them you know even if it's a
tough conversation that you need to have
with them about look you're not quite
hitting this at the moment let's talk
about that why is that is there anything
I can do as a leader to help you get
there you know what's going on
um again it comes down to me to that for
me it comes down to being empathetic
again and understanding that yeah we are
in a sales job but you're dealing with
human beings and trying to get I guess
under the skin of what is really going
on for that person what's driving them
what's motivating them what's holding
them back at the moment so
for me that separation comes from Clear
communication I think you can absolutely
still you know go on socials with them
um you just got to make sure that you're
carrying yourself at all times in a
professional way for me anyway you know
I've never really been the sort of
person to you know get out of hand on a
night out or you know
um well that's just me personally and I
think that's important for people to see
from their leaders as well that you are
being yourself you can you know enjoy
yourself but you've got to remember this
is a work environment whether you're in
work or outside of work you've got to
remember that you're always people are
always going to be looking at you as the
leader so you have to carry yourself in
a certain way hey everyone a real quick
one from me this podcast would not be
possible without our amazing podcast
Partners Vin cherry and Source breaker
because you listen to this podcast
you're able to get your hands on
exclusive savings on both of these
award-winning products if you're a
growing recruitment business you have to
check out vincere who are an all-in-one
operating system for your growing
recruitment business with saucebreaker
if you want to make sure or that all of
your recruiters have the best tools on
the market to stand out and beat their
competition then you have to check out
Source breaker use the link in the show
notes in the comments below and you'll
be able to get yourself exclusive
savings on these amazing products yeah
so let's just get a bit more granular
for a sec on the leadership
um uh point so you can even maybe talk
about when there's then when there was
10 of your Manchester or when there was
the the 13 people there in in the UK
perm team but like speak to a lot of uh
billing managers or
billing leaders oftentimes one of the
the biggest challenges is the the having
don't have enough time to do what he
needs to do you uh the leader have
enough time for the team so like what
how did you approach your weeks like
what were the sort of non-negotiable
management activities that always went
on how did you set your team up let's
just talk about that for a sec because I
think people are always interested in
that did you always make sure Monday
morning there's a weekly kickoff meeting
they do then check with everyone on
Wednesday when did you have your
one-on-ones when did you then have your
own court hours I don't know talk to us
a bit about how you actually approached
the time management and getting the most
out of your time yeah so each day for me
personally I always work from a to-do
list so um I know a lot of people maybe
work from a day plan or you know set
times for everything
um once you become a leader of people
you absolutely have to find a way to
manage your time even more so than you
probably did when you as an individual
contributor so there are certain things
that I would do every single week so the
Monday kickoff is really important for
me that doesn't need to be too long
where it can be helped um I think it
needs to be like short and sharp maybe
15 20 minutes max depending on how many
of you are there what key messages do
you want to land for that week what are
we focusing on as a team how are we
tracking at the moment for the month are
we looking like we're gonna come in on
target above Target are we looking like
we're going to come in behind Target how
do we address that what do we need to do
to correct that
um I would then also have maybe like
five or ten minute like one-to-ones with
people
um so you can get into the diesel and
what their desk needs
um and what it is that they need maybe
to focus on for that week
um and then we'd also have a end of week
catch up as well so uh every Friday as
most companies do you have to end the
week wrap and I think in between that
time
you can be quite I guess fluid as to
maybe when you check in with people
um I I don't like to micromanage I don't
like to constantly be other people
showing you know what you're doing how
are you getting on with that I like to
be available and approachable and my
thing might be just checking in with
them if I maybe hear them on a call and
there's something that I
thing actually yeah
have you thought about maybe saying this
next time or so it might be more on the
desk coaching and quite reactive in that
sense but
um yeah I think the time management
piece is is so important when you're a
billing leader and then you need to just
find time to do your own stuff as well
and that's for me personally I and again
maybe this isn't what a lot of people
want to hear but it is the truth you
know you probably do have to work longer
hours sometimes to get what you need to
get done but for me that comes down to
that personal accountability thing again
I'm not working more hours because you
know Ryan's told me to or you know my
other bosses told me to I'm doing that
because I'm doing what I need to get
done regardless of my situation I need
to find the way to
get certain things done so that my team
can hit our Target for that month so
yeah it's just one of those things but
you know that it's gonna be worth it in
the long term
were there any just on that were there
any like
talking about the things that you had to
do to make sure you're hitting your
number performing lead them by the front
what ended up being like your
non-negotiable activities that you would
like you know what I didn't [__] do
the two hours of BD that because I
missed it now that's catching up on me I
don't know what ended up being like your
personal non-negotiable activities each
week that you felt like if I do these
inputs I should then always end up at
least around where I want to be yeah so
with
um our role in signifies a big building
leader you are tasked with like winning
roles and you know for other people to
work on as well so for me I always knew
that as long as I was bringing in enough
roles for the team to work on then we
should usually get there or thereabouts
in terms of our Target obviously they
need to bring in be bringing in their
own as well but as long as I could find
the way to find roles for us and the
team to work on every single week then
we would usually get there so that's
what my main focus was on like bringing
in more roles for us to work on this
development right so at least so we've
spoken about
leadership the way that you've
approached that
um and I've that I think that really
comes across particularly when you're
talking about just how you've approached
your career like again you're just being
true to yourself and you've approached
um leadership from uh yeah like a what
can I do for you how can I help you
rather than like do this because I've
said do you know what I mean you're not
telling you're not telling people you
are trying to coach people you're trying
to help get the most out of them so when
we prepare for this and I ask you like
what do you think uh people put signal
on fire would sort of say you're most
known for one of the things you said was
around landing and expanding and one of
the things you shared with me that
senior is quite proud of was
um you've been sort of actively involved
in bring on some of the top performing
UK customers for signify so let's just
talk about this because if that's ended
up being fundamental and non-negotiable
for you to keep leading by the front
doing everything you can for your team
besides being a leader was
um new client opportunities and these
things why didn't why don't we just
start with like what what are Dan's
principles to
like Business Development let's just
start there because so many people
listen to this that is what they're
going to be struggling with right now
the Market's more difficult
um there's a lot of people that are
transitioning into 360 recruitment just
it's been it's become a lot more tough I
spoke to so many people have had a
difficult q1 so like firstly what what
are your principles to Business
Development yeah so
for me what's worked really well is that
signify we have a really Niche laser
focus on a back-end programming language
called scholar and the reason why we
chose to focus on scholar was because
it's hard to find there is a lot of
customers that look for that skill set
and these people aren't readily
available they're not really camped out
on job board you know you really have to
go deep into you know searches uh events
meetups to find these people
so
the amount of customers that we've got
into because we focus on scalar is
incredible uh we've worked with some
amazing Brands because of the fact that
we are scarlet specialists and I use
that to be honest and I think that's you
know something that maybe businesses
should focus on you know what's going to
be your in to get into these companies
what's the thing that makes you
different you know there are however
many recruitment companies out there so
I it's Ryan when you set up signify I
was like I'm gonna make sure I give my
team everything they need to go out
there and be successful and that was the
hunting impacts mentality for these
Scarlet developers so just on that just
quickly like what does that actually
sound like like when you're speaking to
clients because a lot yeah if you're
listening to this right now and you're
not in the niche you're not entirely
focused like you're always going to
struggle so like what I I'd probably say
a lot of people uh do have that in uh
Armory but it's like how they use it do
you know what I mean so like what does
that actually sound like then are you
basically calling people say like hey
the reason why uh you should give me an
opportunity or why you should listen to
me is that we only do Scarlet that's all
we do we're in the communities we're in
the trenches we're only speaking to
these people which means yeah a lot of
the time you might find yourself speak
to other agencies that they do Scarlet
but they also do JavaScript they also do
these things like what does it actually
sound like when you're do you know what
I mean yeah it's not far off that to be
honest with you and
what we do I say probably 75 of our day
when we were you know when I was a
consultant and what the Consultants do
now and signify is that they're speaking
to candidates all day long you know
finding out information about the market
you know who's hiring who's not hiring
what projects are they working on what
technologies are they using alongside
Scala and we're Gathering all that
information so that when we go and
approach those companies who we know are
hiring we're coming there armed with
facts and information that makes us
sound credible add to that the fact that
we're Scarlet Specialists you know why
wouldn't they give us a chance we know
that you're struggling to hire for
scholar we know that you use this
technology that technology alongside
Scala we know that you've got this
project coming up and we've actually got
someone who's just finished on the
project for another company which is
identical to what you guys are doing so
would you like to see the CV he's
available for an interview you know
later on this week today tomorrow
whatever that might be so you've got to
go in there with confidence and knowing
that you are absolutely adding value to
these people
um I think the mistake that we can
sometimes make is
um you know going into these calls and
just assuming that asking the question
of right have you got vacancies uh yes
no
um that's enough you have to be adding
value I mean it's that value add
um which helps us to stand out and I
genuinely believe it now is all right I
think if there's any company who are
hiring for scholar Engineers why
wouldn't you talk to us so that that's
just my thinking it probably comes
across in a way that you know I do BD
now the team do Beauty and why we've got
into some of these amazing customers
that we work with Okay so we've got so
the first thing is making sure that yeah
like what you're I feel like we're
talking about there is
um one of your principles is making sure
that you're known for something you're
an expert in something you can also
showcase credibility uh to the people
that you're prospecting speaking to
because like you said you'll speak to
all these people you can offer
information insights which is really
valuable what what are some of the other
principles then do you think that you've
really bought into or applied to your
credits enabled you and maybe your team
to get the most out of their business
development yeah so the other thing that
we do really well is the I guess
non-recruitment activities so we're
really big on uh sponsoring conferences
uh attending conferences uh hosting our
own monthly meet up as well called
scholar in the city
um we've also done workshops where we
actually train people to learn Scala
whether that's at a really Junior entry
level right through to you know super
Advanced you know next level
um type um ability so
um those are all things which again you
know credit to Ryan you know these are
all ideas that he had which made me
believe in him and use that in my armor
when I was speaking to customers about
why they should be using us so those um
those community events are absolutely
one of the main reasons why we've been
so successful in winning customers and
and delivering for those customers as
well and again what like what is that
look like you know what I mean like
because I understand I understand that
completely and I think there are more
and more recruitment businesses that do
try and build communities do offer
events uh so like what again
particularly if we just have the
business development Focus like what
does that actually look like then in
terms of like uh like leveraging that
and how does that show up on you getting
two amazing new clients each month
because you're doing those things like
are you does it enable you to open up
the doors open up more doors because you
can call people and go hey don't want to
speak to you about your vacancies you
want to feature about Scotland a city
and why it could be something that could
be interesting for your team like how
does it actually tangibly turn into
commercials because that's going to be a
big part of it along with the giving
back that all you guys do which I see
all the check the money they raise for
charity you're doing a good thing by
trying to get more people uh learning
about scholar unable to do it so you're
trying to reduce skill gaps you're
building a community a lot obviously
there's all these other great things but
100 is a direct directing it's also
impacting the the commercials right so
what does it actually look like how do
you actually utilize those assets yeah
you've got to think long term with this
stuff
um because a lot of the community staff
um isn't immediate quick wins although
you might get them you have to go into
it for that long-term mindset and that
what I'm doing here is I'm getting
myself in front of these people with a
different conversation that they may be
having with all the other hundreds of
recruiters are calling them or sending
them sending them messages or emails
um I'm differentiating myself to get
myself in front of them and open up that
conversation so with those once those
doors are opened you've then got to
think I'm not thinking about this as
right I'm gonna get a deal with them
right now or play some of them right now
you have to be thinking I'm I'm gonna be
genuinely sharing information with them
and not expect anything in return right
now
um but what I have done is I've shown
them I'm credible I've shown them who I
am as a person as well that's all the
other thing that people don't I think
sometimes take into consideration is
that it's a people game you've got to
put yourself out there put yourself in
front of people then if I can show these
clients that I'm credible I know what
I'm talking about and I'm actually a
pretty decent person he's a human being
and I can deliver for them why wouldn't
they use me you know whether they've got
a vacancy right now or maybe they've got
you know uh red tape or psls that don't
allow them to work with me right now
further on down the line if that
opportunity opens up they will be
thinking of me because of all the work
that I've put into developing that
relationship showing that I understand
their business showing them why they
need to be working with us um you've got
to think long term with this stuff yeah
so yeah it sounds like it enables you to
open up doors to then showcase what
you're about how you're different or
that so I think that leads quite nicely
onto the land and expand like Focus
point because I think
um I'd love to just get your take on
yeah how you believe you've been able to
do that and we can get as tactical as
you want because I think a lot of
recruiters are when we think of BD it's
uh very
um tactical and reactive and what I mean
by that is I've got a candidate I call
five different companies I think that
candidate could work for and it's
specking and it's like have you got
opportunities now are you hiring right
now and it's very short term and it's
very like okay well you're not hiring at
the moment okay no worries I'm gonna
focus on the next company on the next
company but then what you were just
talking about I'd probably say more
falls into the of like strategic BD
right whereas it's a bit more longer
term and it's like okay well this could
actually really
um help
um have a big impact in three months six
months so how and I think a lot of
recruiters will get a job uh they fill
it might be ones and twos and then they
only that that's it for that entire year
so what what have you what have you done
differently to make sure that it's not
just ones and twos and these accounts
become big accounts like have you got
introductions to other hiring managers
did you get in initially with one team
and then showed what you're about and
then go okay well can you now introduce
us to these like how have you approached
landing and expanding what how can we do
that better yeah for me it all starts
with delivery so whenever you do get
that chance to work a job for them you
have to deliver really [__] well you
have to give them a level of service
that you'd be proud of
um and once you delivered really well
for them for me that's when it opens up
the door to go and meet with them again
meetings is something which I think are
probably underrated in recruitment to be
honest um I always try and get out and
meet with my clients face to face and a
lot of the time to be honest it might be
a social one they might be taking them
out for drinks or especially when we
place with them you know they've
actually generated revenue for the
company I'm looking to meet with them
and thank them for giving me the
opportunity getting to know them more in
a personal level and that's what
naturally leads to them recommending off
to people internally as well we're
asking that question they know that
we've done a good job for them we've
delivered really well
um they've met me in person now
um so it's a lot more easier for them to
recommend me to someone internally and
what I found personally has happened
with the accounts that I have landed and
expanded in is we've delivered really
well on their tough as roles their tough
as roles which are scholar and they've
then spoken to another person internally
another key stakeholder and said look
you're struggling with your role I've
used signify for my scholar roles which
are really hard and they've come to us
and said look we know you're Scarlet
specialist but could you also help us
with these business analyst roles or
project manager roles so although we
focus on Scala that's what we outwardly
go and win in terms of Business
Development we definitely do other stuff
as well but it's usually with accounts
that we've delivered for on the scholar
side so we've just given them a really
high level of service on the scholar
side met with them in person and that's
naturally led to them recommending us to
other key stakeholders in the business
who are also then happy to use US based
on the recommendation of someone
internally which is so powerful so where
do people go wrong with it then then
like if I've delivered am I not asking
the question am I not committing to
continuing to build a relationship am I
not following up uh with them like I
might have done the placement and then
it's like I don't end up speaking for
another four or six weeks like where
because I'm sure you have your team in
this like where where do people go wrong
with just ended up doing one twos and
three placements with customers where it
could actually be fives and tens yeah
to how fast-moving recruitment is and
there's always something new coming up
you know you always start to win new
customers but
I'm a big believer in like looking after
what you've got as well you know if um
you know if you really look after what
you've got you look after it well then
you know you're going to be getting more
from that account and you can replicate
that with other accounts but I think
very often we're very quick to jump to
the next thing
um I think asking the question is right
as well actually mapping out that
customer looking online at what other
vacancies they have and saying look by
the way I've noticed that you guys have
got uh you know another job advertise
for front-end developer
um we can actually help with that as
well we've done a similar with another
customer that we work with
um who is it that's looking after that
position can you make the introduction
for me you know constantly looking at
the customers that you do have and think
what else can we get out of them
so as we come to the end here then what
what we're saying for Manchester how
how's it looking what what's what's
exciting for for this year for you guys
yeah so we are Manchester is obviously
the newest office uh in signify so we've
got London where we first started then
it was la which is where Ryan is now ask
been uh so Manchester is the the newest
office in um in the signify team
and really excitingly we've hired like
quite a few senior people recently who
have come with you know really good
track record
um we brought in a another director
actually as well who's going to be
focused more on the actual
um I guess day-to-day management which
allows me to go out and do what my
strengths are which is focusing on the
winning more customers selling some of
our non-recruitment type services and
propositions
um and I'm really excited about that
because that's where my strengths lies
what I'm good at
um and we are growing as well we're
still hiring we're expanding
um the future's bright the future is
really bright for Manchester I'm really
looking forward to seeing what we can do
this year
um and we've got a really strong team in
place now as well yeah I love that well
look down uh absolutely like from the
very uh beginning like honestly just
absolutely love your mindset I think
honestly like particularly obviously in
recruitment but just in in life in
general I think one of the best things
that you can do is just cultivate a
mindset that can help you in in life and
yeah just loved hearing you talking
about personal responsibility your
approach to leadership just being a good
human
you know like I said you don't you don't
have to be a dick to have success in
recruitment
um so yeah look respect I think what an
amazing journey that you've been on in
uh going on this journey with one of
your really great friends and be part of
a business Journey uh that yeah has
obviously been an exciting one right
where you're one of the very early
employees and you just go on this
trajectory a lot of people would have
been sort of in an interview room and
going down we're gonna we've got big
plans we're gonna grow all that
sometimes it doesn't happen but you
you've been part of this journey so I'm
sure you'll look back and go wow what
what a journey that was and you'll
continue to go on it still feel just as
excited as as um you are probably at the
beginning so
thanks for coming on my man thank you
very much I really appreciate you having
me on and I guess saying to you as well
I'm a big fan of what you do and I know
when we had the prep call earlier so you
guys asking you know so what is the the
conglomerate that you've made it was so
fascinating to hear about that and I
think what you're doing is it's
definitely needed in the recruitment
industry it's something which when I
first started would have been unheard of
to be honest it's genuinely sharing of
information and people wanting each
other to get better
um who might be deemed as competitors
but there's enough out there for
everyone to win there really is and I
think you know stuff like this helps to
raise the bar
um in recruitment so I appreciate you
yeah hey man love that bro thank you
thank you thank you so much for
listening to the episode I hope you
enjoyed it and got value from the
conversation if you did enjoy it please
don't forget to like share and subscribe
and we'll see you in the next episode
all right